What is an elimination Matrix? So now we have to talk about types of
matrices? Let's first talk about the identity Matrix.
Then let's let me show you how to get to to a lower
triangle Matrix and then you will understand what we mean by elimination matrices.
Let's say we have this Square Matrix.
We want to factorize this Matrix. We want
to extract from this Matrix.
the L Matrix and the U Matrix
to get to the you Matrix. We must first do the
L Matrix.
To get to the old Matrix. We need a sequence of
elimination matrices.
Here's the idea.
In the previous example where we use Gauss elimination.
Yes, we did those raw operations, but we did not keep
track.
of which
numbers we use
or what order we used.
Well, I guess we could say we keptract because here I
have.
Replaced R2, but that's not what I mean. When I
say keeping track of the operations. I mean having a
matrix.
Or a collection of matrices that says you did
this to Row 1 and then you do this to row two and then you
do this to row three and these are written in matrices. Now what
I actually mean let me show you so I'm gonna keep this here
and I'm gonna open LED composition that IP ynb
Okay, once again, I will import.
Numpy as and P.
And then I'm gonna recreate this Matrix.
The first thing we are going to do is
what we want to do is again, we want to get to Upper triangular form,
right so we want
this to be 0
and then these two to be 0
okay this to be 0 is to be zero
this to be 0 and everything across the diagonal should be
a non-zero value.
How would we get rid of?
Negative 3 that's the first thing we need to make zero.
Well, let's see one way to get rid of three.
Is to First multiply this row by three.
So this would come 3.
This would become six that will become negative 9 but we
don't care about these two what's important to us? Is that if we
multiply this row by three, then we
could add these two together.
3 plus negative 3 would cancel out row two.
And as far as we're concerned that's considered elimination.
Now I can use the same code I did another file.
As zero plus S2, but that's Gauss
and elimination. We don't want to do calcium lamination. Okay, let
me show you what I mean.
Now this I will denote as a
And then I'm going to create a matrix called I called NP
dot array. This is going to be the identity Matrix
that I've been talking about.
What's in the identity Matrix?
You have a square Matrix. That is the
same size as the Matrix to what you want to
multiply this identity Matrix and we have
these values. Basically I an identity Matrix
is a matrix with
zeros everywhere except across the diagonal
the main diagonal. Why is it called identity Matrix?
Let me show you I will show you the result of this evaluation and
then I'll show you a picture. I'm going to
go NP.
dot mat more
this is short for matrix multiplication.
So I'm going to apply the identity Matrix to the
original Matrix.
When I multiply this you can see we get
the same Matrix again.
I mean, it's the same thing. How was it possible? So I'm
going to pull up a picture of Matrix.
Multiplication this is a good example the way
you will multiply two matrices.
Is with multiply well the first number.
In the first row times the first
number in the First Column of the second row. If you
look at the picture you should get the idea and then there's some
of these two products. So two times three zero times four that
would become the first value in the resulting
Matrix.
the by arranging the numbers and identity Matrix
Like what we just saw we will get back the same resulting Matrix.
You can take a second or two to look at this. So one times a
And then zero times C. And
then zero times e holy see
these zeros right these zeros.
are going to cancel out the other terms and
all you left is one times a
and what times e is just a
look at this so that you're convinced that.
The identity Matrix will give you the the original Matrix.